[Music]
the past isn't dead
james fate draws us back together
[Music]
now your enemy's my enemy
his name is saffin and what does he want
revenge me when her secret finds its way
out
it'll be the death of you
you can imagine why i've come back to
play
there's a young lady in santiago i want
you to meet you're late
when you're ready
she's a disarming young woman i get why
you shot him
yeah well everyone tries at least once
james bond
we both eradicate people
to make the world a better place i just
want to be a little
tidier
come on bond where the hell are you
harder to tell the good from bad
villains from heroes these days
if we don't do this
there will be nothing left to say
[Music]
the white dots on the screen the
adrenaline start pumping
and then bonds turning towards the
barrel and firing when that comes out
it's korean it's like
to settle in and get ready for a ride
for me as a writer and a director it was
essential to rediscover bond
where is he after five years of
retirement who has he become
he's sort of a wounded animal struggling
with his role as a double
o the world's changed the rules of
engagement aren't what they used to be
the rules of espionage darker in this
era of asymmetric warfare
the people close to bond those he
considers to be family are at great risk
and now there's someone new out there
more dangerous than anyone he's ever
encountered and whoever they are
is smarter and stronger than spectre
from the moment he's called to action to
the end of the film as a race
not only to save the world but their
lives
no time to die is the culmination of all
that bond has become
with all that he's seen all the trauma
the loss what is that mission that will
be his most challenging and most
difficult
that was our target we aim to do
something extraordinary with this one
every bond film has that thing the
danger
but also the emotional punch
everything that was left unsaid will
finally be said
this will be the final chapter for drama
craig
[Music]
why would i betray you we all have our
secrets
we just didn't get to yours yet
the world is arming faster than we can
respond
where's double 07.
i need a favor brother you're the only
one i trust for this
the world's moved on commander bond you
were double o
two years so stay in your lane
you get in my way i will put a bullet in
your knee
the one that works i thought you two
would get along
name bond
james bond so you're not dead hello pew
i've missed you
it's the most valuable asset this
country has if you feel yourself losing
control
i'm not going to lose
patrol
james you gave up everything for her
when her secret finds its way out it'll
be the death of him
what is it you don't know what this is
james bond license to kill
history of violence
i could be speaking to my own reflection
only your skills die with your body
mine will survive long after i'm gone
history isn't kind to men who play god
[Music]
[Applause]
do
[Music]
you